I got to ask spoiler questions but I
thought I could just ask them you could
answer we'll bleep them out so where's
the soul stone okay great is in the
movie No okay what's the Stan Lee cameo
he's what are the after credit scenes
talking to the guy who just woke up from
the coma yeah and telling him which cut
of meat he is a pork chop who are you
[Laughter]
incredibly dehydrated yeah is there any
full frontal Hulk nudity that's all the
time we got the bar mitzvah is loading
in Avengers infinity war is in theaters
now thank you guys thank you so much
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what it exactly is it that we're
doing oh this is something you always do
at the end of a Marvel movie the credits
play and then for the people that stick
around the theater afterwards there's
this cool extra part that no one knew
was gonna happen and this is that part
yeah surprise treat for the people for
the people that stuck around through the
entire credits yeah exactly
well but I mean how is this a treat I
mean shouldn't it be funny it doesn't
have to be funny yeah I mean sometimes
they're funny but sometimes they just
introduced the villain who's coming up
in the next one you get to see that
villain for the first time oh so we're
just waiting for the next villain to
show up yeah hello gentlemen oh good
yeah that worked out I've never related
much to the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
did watch Lou Ferrigno played The
Incredible Hulk as a child in the 70s of
course his name should be pronounced
Farini oh the Italian way he is of
Italian descent but he pronounces it for
regno so I'm happy to call it for Rigg
no it's an Americanized pronunciation to
me it was really Bill Bixby that added
the dimension to that David Banner
character of course in the comics called
Bruce Banner changed by a CBS executive
as rumor has it
you